this morning amnesty international says
russian authorities may be slowly trying
to kill
president vladimir putin's most public
critic alexi navalny is a prisoner
inside a russian penal colony and his
supporters say
navalny suffers from severe pain and is
being denied medical treatment
our holly williams now has the latest on
the efforts to see him
even behind bars alexei navalny is
causing trouble for the russian
government
russian police detained nine people
yesterday when his supporters
including his personal physician tried
to gain access to navalny in prison
i'm very really very afraid of his
health and
his condition that's why i'm here now do
you trust the prison doctor no
navalny started a hunger strike a week
ago a protest against the russian
authorities denying him access to his
doctors
the outspoken opponent of the russian
government says he's suffering from
acute leg
and back pain navalny was sentenced to
two and a half years behind bars in
february for violating parole
a case his supporters say was
politically motivated
it followed his near-fatal poisoning
last august
with the nerve agent novichok which
navalny blames on russia's leaders
a russian government source recently
released this cctv footage of navalny in
prison
the russian authorities say he's
receiving all necessary
medical assistance alexey navalny's
lawyer says he's lost
28 pounds since he was locked up and is
suffering from sleep deprivation
anthony ali williams in london thank you
holly